tu es heureux de vivre quand même
la famille
felsinati débarsviller en Moselle
passent ces heures de loisirs à
fabriquer des maquettes jusque là rien
de bien original le papa Edmond la maman
Ginette la fille Astrid les trois
garçons Daniel Marc et Christian adorent
travailler de leurs mains mais les
maquettes qu'il confectionnent sont pour
le moins inhabituelles quand de
concentration pour crématoire cimetière
militaire cela pour les modèles réduits
mais également grandeur nature
dépotances et une guillotine pour
célébrer le bicentenaire de la
Révolution une entreprise à première vue
un petit peu macabre mais dont le but
est humanitaire car la production des
falcinnaties fera au printemps prochain
objet d'une exposition dans les
bénéfices iront aux associations
d'anciens combattants et aux
associations de charité reportage sur
cette famille de Frédéric Chignac
[Musique]
monsieur felcinati est-ce que vous êtes
un pessimiste pas du tout un bricoleur
démoniaque
peut-être mais certainement pas
dans le ciel par-dessus le toit il y a
de la joie et du soleil dans les ruelles
arrêtoir une minute
qu'on a fait combien bon
avec je ne sais quoi
alors il me faut absolument s'en
cercueil pour ce soir tu sais ce que tu
as à faire
[Musique]
la nuit Edmond felicinati il dort mais
pas toujours parfois il se réveille pour
résoudre les problèmes des maquettes
qu'il a en tête et le jour pendant les
heures de loisirs toute la famille
mettait exécution si l'on peut dire elle
fonctionne la guillotine oui elle
fonctionne la guillotine le poids
coulisseau couteau ps40 kg et vous avez
donc une force de 250 kg sur le
tranchant de la lame donc il y a pas de
pardon la tête elle tombe
pourquoi vous fabriquez des choses aussi
effrayantes c'est bizarre comme idée
ce que j'expose là je peux pas le
changer moi je peux pas changer le cours
de l'histoire quand on voit pas la
potence qui était le symbole des nazis
on va dire quoi de concentration des
fours crématoires tout ça c'est pas beau
des jeunes aujourd'hui ne savent pas
donc j'ai pensé que avec une telle
exposition ben on pourrait effectivement
que des jeunes soient conscients de ce
qui s'est passé quoi
ah d'accord si c'est pour que les
erreurs passées ne se répètent pas mais
c'est quand même pas une raison pour
être si triste
vous aimez la vie ah oui bien sûr vous
faites pas des choses plus gaies alors
peut-être qu'un jour j'y penserai
j'ai pensé peut-être à jour
ça fait quel effet d'être ici je sais
que écouter
[Musique]